gritos y pancartas contra la persecución
política esto es lo que se ha vivido
este jueves en hong kong frente al
tribunal de caolín occidental que
declaró culpables a 7 opositores por
organización y participación en una
manifestación no autorizada el 18 de
agosto de 2019 es un verdadero honor
haber formado parte del histórico 18 de
agosto con 17 millones de personas en la
marcha incluso si tenemos que ir a
prisión por ello
la protesta se enmarca dentro de las
manifestaciones antigubernamentales que
se desataron tras la aprobación en junio
de 2019 de la ley de extradición
los manifestantes temían que dicha ley
permitiera a beijing juzgar a hong kong
heces en la china continental tras las
masivas manifestaciones beijing desató
una ofensiva contra la disidencia que se
alarga hasta ahora
en este día de ajuste de cuentas la
represión política es igual para todos
los que han participado en el movimiento
de protesta incluso sin importar donde
estén los pacíficos o los más valientes
todos están atrapados bajo esta ola de
represión política
todos los acusados menos el magnate de
prensa jimmy light y nunca un conocido
como pelo largo quedarán libres bajo
fianza si bien no podrán abandonar hong
kong o similares propietario del
tabloide apple daily y destacado
opositor a beijing fue juzgado por
corrupción tras reunirse con figuras
como mike pence o mike pompeo a lo largo
es un conocido luchador anticolonialista
por la independencia de formación
trotskista conocido en el parlamento por
sus camisetas reivindicativas con la
imagen del ché la sentencia llega
después de la reforma electoral de
beijing que reduce la influencia de la
oposición en el parlamento de hong kong
el próximo 16 de abril se conocerán las
penas que podrían ir de los 12 a los 18
meses de cárcel